brought to you by The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt available now hello and welcome to
the lobby GameSpot's weekly hangout
every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right
here on Gamescom I'm your host Daniel
Dwyer joined as ever by mr. Christopher
waters hi Danny
fantastic shirt as ever thank you uh you
can address me as the white wolf okay
now long after our the promo art for
this week yeah chef Anthony every week
every week look at that look at that is
fantastic
you see that looks my hair eterna silver
so the problem is that Anthony has to go
with like five pictures of us that have
been taken wearing the same clothes in
the same thing same positions like same
expressions so his way around it was
like a mad face just because it's more I
put a mad face on video game characters
more easily than like so he straight up
like there's a little personality as
well yeah it is I'm simmering with rage
underneath but I'm just real happy they
didn't do the wild wolf on me because
I'm a little bit self-conscious about
the gray hair thing there so chef needed
know it's true could have saved about an
hour of thumbnail production time and
today we are very happy to be joined by
mr. Jason a striker I'm calm thank you
very much for having me I have you here
for one very very good reason cuz we're
such good friends
of course because we're wonderful
friends and also because you were paying
The Witcher yes I mean we can buttload
of The Witcher hmm so it's finally out
it's out today for public consumption PC
Xbox one PlayStation 4 all over the
place what were you playing over the
weekend what version over the weekend we
got code for the Xbox one version and I
was initially having some issues with
the with that running but ok it turned
out it was all on my side like there was
a caching issue but once once I got that
sorted out it was still stuttering a
little bit yeah they're like you know it
definitely seems to be like my wife saw
for the first time she's like are you
playing on the 360 oh no I don't say I
sing it in the open-world areas though
yeah we're like foliage is a little flat
and whatnot but when you're in cutscenes
and everything Matt some of the textures
like I don't like to throw out the word
stunning yeah
games pretty damn good-looking
especially on PC now yeah don't say so I
guess this is where we get into at the
moment Rob is doing a graphics
comparison where he hasn't
at 60 frames a second a 2k I'm playing
on Xbox one and it looks great it looks
great on Xbox one do you think it's good
on ps4 I've played about two hours last
night and did that thing where you know
like you you slow down and sort of Pan
the camera around to just see the Sun
sets or you know even the interior of
the first in you go into just like the
vibrant like paintings on the wall and
then like little flower decorations
hanging like that detail and that visual
vibrancy yeah it's it's a looker so yeah
I'm right there with you I think it
looks really good on Xbox one I'm kind
of surprised too happy but surprised
about that but I'm not going in to have
a look at it on 60 frames a second like
you on PC have you seen a big difference
in mice will you yeah yeah it was a
night and day difference like I started
again yeah I started again and actually
kind of win at my own pace so like all
those like undiscovered locations that I
saw like in my first playthrough I
discovered the hell out of those so yeah
I took my time I'm not quite as far as I
was when I played over them again but
that was just like six hours of gameplay
last night Wow and so we talked a little
bit last week about that the game is
sort of the broad strokes when we had
Kevin on for our review of course the
ninth tenet down on gamespot comms
history and that's great let's talk
about some of the quests and stay away
from the main quest stuff just look at
some of the like interesting little
stories anecdotes you've had playing the
the early part of this game and is there
any interesting stories that like pop
out to you over the past like couple
days what's been amazing to me is like
how fleshed out and well-written
like all of these side stories are in
comparison to you like The Witcher 2
which really starts out with a bang oh
yeah literally cuz you're in bed with
Tris but the throw you into a big battle
there's you know big dragon and
everything but in this it's very subdued
you go through that initial like
tutorial section which ends up being a
flashback but after that they're just
like hey go find yennefer hmm so I'm
like alright this this we'll see how
this goes and I started talking to more
NPCs and I'm like these guys seem kind
of placeholder but I'm actually
interested in what they're having to say
so everything seems so well written that
it's it's engrossed me in a different
way than then witcher 2 did yeah i'm
surprised by the question mark hunting
stuff you're talking about it's probably
one of the most thing
started to pick like peninsulas I just
been like I'm gonna spend the next
Superman it's just I just like did like
you know like this area of the maps look
like it doesn't have anything going on I
wonder if there's something happening
there and there's always like a bunch of
stuff happening in there yeah I was on
the quest for did I was looking for some
brutes at riverbed or something like
that part of a side quest and and there
was an old lady with an exclamation
point above her head and she's like
peeking in the windows of his old hut
and I'm like I lady what do you go up to
and she starts telling me about her
night on some creepy guy was trying to
get her frying pan and ended up
borrowing it and like all right lady
she's like the frying pans right there
let me go get it mmm so you go do it and
you find out that there's like a grisly
murder inside and there's like intrigue
there's like a spy notes all over the
place and you know after every time that
you look at something she's like it's
your Fried find my primary yeah so a lot
of that moment is you go into a hut pick
up a pan and bring it out to an old lady
who is like distraught she lost her
right hand yeah but it's so full of
character and it's so interesting that
it's just like yeah I want to look at
those excellent and it unearths yeah a
whole other side chain of events that
you can you can dive into I just had
this part where I played hide-and-seek
with a bunch of kids to get information
off them oh I'm pretty sure I could have
intimidated them but that was just like
whenever I've got Witcher sense this
isn't gonna take long what and then one
of them had like climbed up on the roof
of the building and I had to like climb
up and then down into a hay bale and I
was like there you are I found you and
you're like yeah but you family lasts so
she was like delighted because it was
like you got any last concern
hopefully I wouldn't be amazed of the
mental manipulation sign on children yes
they documented I had this one boy
telling me that like I asked I'm looking
for Siri and it's not this that this is
love baby Siri but I'm at one stage
where I'm like asking this kid we're
serious and he's like I don't know man
apparently all the girls with titties go
into the water
and I was like wasa he was like this
little child and he's like yeah my dad
used to tell me that the girls go when
the soldiers come the girls with the
nice titties go into the woods and I'm
like okay yeah do you want to play hide
and seek is this getting pretty awkward
you want to try to reclaim some of your
lost child
oh yeah this kids totally an orphan by
the way so like Dom's
and that part that's quest stuff as
where you get into like the bog later
when you're looking for there's somebody
or Crowley right yeah yeah but I keep
getting like sides tracked I'm not an
easy to I think like there's so many
open-world games like when I think about
where Assassin's Creed kind of is and
and maybe Far Cry 4 which was good fun
but summer a lot of those side quests
are very like collectathon yeah like par
for the course you're kind of like oh
I've got 15 of these you know collect
the feather quests and 15 of these and
destroy the outpost and there is some of
that stuff here but like monster holes
and whatnot but it tends to be a lot
more varied and and yeah like there's a
lot more ways like mechanically when
you're in the missions that they're sort
of like you said like all you're doing
is going up picking up a frying pan and
bringing it back to her but they just do
stuff to like dress that way that in a
way that makes it like entertaining
that's so true I like you know we're
looking for UN efforts really early on I
went to the bounty board sounds like or
I'll read what's going on and lo and
behold it's not just like a list of
quests it's like random posts from
people they're just fun to read but I
took one that was like uh oh I need to
get to this well but it's haunted yeah
kind of messed up so you go and you talk
to the guy he tells you why he needs to
get there you roll up to this little
town this little settlement that has the
well and perfect figure out pretty
quickly it's guarded by a wraith yeah
but it's not you don't just go to that
well fight the Wraith and then go back
to the dude you like search the houses
and all the while Geralt is doing his
like investigation matter where he's
kind of talking to himself about like uh
about what a Witcher is and what he does
like it's informing you of that and then
you know you you end up like doing some
more stuff and then he's like alright I
need to prepare for this fight so it's
almost like a little short tutorial yeah
it's a tutorial it has that in there but
but it's that doesn't feel like a
disorder doesn't feel like that and it
also you know you're learning about like
Geralt in an authentic way but the thing
that struck me with that was these are
quests like this world is so full of
grief yeah and so full and like with
your orphan comment like this world is
full of people whose lives are like torn
apart by loss even when there's not a
war going on yeah yeah but because of
all these creatures in these horrors
like death and grief are such a part of
people's lives and that quest
specifically we're like the Wraith is a
physical manifestation of this horrible
green yeah echoing in the world that had
this like resonance with me that just
yeah I mean that quest writing is just
so it's grabbed me right yeah it doesn't
dive into the sort of melodrama you
associate with a lot of high fantasy
stuff it's kind of more grounded I
remember there was one part your there's
this disease like fight clubs that are
in different times and we should join in
and you can bet on yourself and go into
Fight Club and there was one of them and
like if it was any other game it would
just be like Oh fight that guy fight
that guy fight that guy like in a row
but I went to this one I bet like 35
gold or whatever on me winning the fight
and it was just some fisherman and then
he's like oh please the winner of this
gets a bag of flour and I'm starving
like just like the winner of this like
bout I like oh my [ __ ] kidding me
so like I decided to spend like in that
video gaming way like I decided who
knows if I do something nice for him
maybe I'll get something back sure so I
did the fight and I bet him within an
inch of his life and then stopped
blocking and he bat me up and sure
enough he wins and he gets the flower
and nothing nothing and I was kind of
like okay I don't mind and then like I
come back two hours later and like he's
still like reigning champion so I went
in and I know I could beat the crap out
of him so I like bet twice as much like
the top limit just pounded the [ __ ] out
was like a you got your food and I just
made my money back so we're all the
world yeah I was a bunch of them swerves
like that there's there's a there's a
guy that needs help on the side of the
road like apparently you know his cart
had been driven off the road by these
drowners or whatever yeah coming to find
out through some investigation that he's
actually the guy that shot it down when
you confront him about it he gets like
completely dim-witted and he's like uh
look behind you trying to run away
he's run yeah he hops on a horse he
started chasing after this this idiot
right and you knock him off the horse
and come to find out that he's actually
a spy for like the rebels of the air oh
wow yeah the lock box that he wanted you
to obtain actually has medical supplies
for his his homies Wow so you have the
choice of you know giving it back to him
or keeping it or a dead big swerve and
it's sad I'm the senior citizen don't I
was like really
you go on your way with your life but
Witcher gets paid okay last one cuz I
don't want to go away with me anymore
spoilery stuff had any of you guys very
early but yes super early have any of
you guys seen the the gentleman outside
of was a crows parch who has to beat up
a hundred Knights to get like the honor
of this woman Edna and like he's on 99
he's on 99 and he comes up to Gareth and
you're like mais les so he pulls out his
sword I tried to convince him not and it
wouldn't work and so now I didn't fight
him because I was like I don't wanna
kill this guy cuz he seems like a nice
dude every time I go back to crows perch
he's waiting for me
he's ready for the flu that get off
there Zak I'm Gerald I automatically
pulls out his sword and I'm like no just
keep going right just give you a doll
take a swing just let the guy live it
got out I kinda wanna see what happens
if you if you kill him yeah alright so
one here's a question though this is I
you can hat you've got multiple save
slots you can have manual shaves what
are your personal philosophies about
saving sticking with your decisions
where we at I tend to stick with them
but last night I had the fortunate
opportunity to like replay some of the
stuff that I had oh yeah for alright
yeah I show some different news
different things yeah like there's a
gentleman that you talk to the Emperor
actually he can choose whether or not to
bow oh yeah to him so I chose the
opposite and yeah he treated me
completely different oh really a
conversation it was did you badly second
time did not bout the sec I didn't bet
both times I've done it the first time
I've out yet which was kind of a
humorous thing the first time but but
you got that you literally have to learn
the bow you have to do like the hand
knee in right arm you have to like yeah
oh really
yeah get your super smart and really
good the one thing I've seen on Xbox one
I'm not sure if it's the same for ps4 or
but it's probably different on PC is
that there's a maximum eight of manual
save slots so you can't like oblivion it
and I've got 300 yeah um PC it seems to
just keep good going
yeah yeah I usually like leapfrog what I
have multiple saves sure but personally
I haven't I think I'm gonna try to stick
with stick through yet with the
decisions I'm with you I did the same
for Mass Effect on the mass spec too and
I was lucky enough that I got everyone
through that but I was like this is it
if it doesn't work out this weekend
that's tough because I mean there's what
36 total
to something that yeah and your choices
carry so much weight that it's it's
tough to make those especially like the
split decision yes and we gave K
GameSpot gave the Witcher through Walt
onto ten and ten you guys think it's
right up there I think it's I think it's
up there I think there definitely some
technical issues yeah but if CD Projekt
RED has proven anything is that you know
they they continue to support the game
but post release so I have no no worry
that they'll sort it out excellent yeah
so far so good for me cool looking
forward to play more with your three
wall tones over the next couple of weeks
and perhaps months if you want to see
more of our coverage go over to GameSpot
calm and let us know in the comments
what you think of your time would Geralt
of Rivia
you